salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
je suis sûr qu'il vous est déjà arrivé
vous aussi d'avoir du mal à enregistrer
des noms de personnes de lieu des dates
des numéros de téléphone j'ai peut-être
la solution je connais un NAS de la
mémoire Fabien olicard il nous attend
dans l'atelier je crois qu'il a décidé
de me mettre des filles
salut Fabien salut les amis au cas où
certaines te connaîtraient pas tu es
très connu pour ton activité de
mentalisme mais ça c'est le côté
spectacle en revanche tu es également un
super athlète de la mémoire en fait on a
tous une très bonne mémoire disons qu'on
a tous le même cerveau avec le même de
rôle les mêmes connexions entre chacun
de ces neurones et évidemment sauf pour
les personnes qui ont des problèmes de
maladie neurodégénatrice comme Alzheimer
on a tous la capacité à se forger une
bonne mémoire à partir de ce bon cerveau
j'ai même moins envie d'essayer de
tester ta mémoire en donnant des
conseils évidemment qui vont te
permettre d'exploiter cette mémoire
alors parfois on entend quand même dire
des gens ah j'ai pas de mémoire oh j'ai
une très mauvaise mémoire salut sens ou
pas ça a du sens en terme de croyance on
peut croire qu'on a une mauvaise mémoire
mais on discute avec ces personnes et on
s'aperçoit que si la personne est fan de
football elle connaît le nom de tous les
joueurs depuis 10 ans donc en fait c'est
une mauvaise utilisation de la mémoire
est-ce que tu es prêt à relever le défi
je vais le relever évidemment avec grand
plaisir et je suis sûr que tout ce qui
nous suivent vont le relever en même
temps on va faire quelque chose que tu
connais je vais te donner un numéro de
téléphone comme dans la vraie vie tu as
pas de quoi le noter l'assure-toi
actuellement et non j'ai pas de
téléphone pour éviter les interférences
mais tu as un super bloc-notes ici donc
tu vas devoir le retenir comme ça tu me
le donnes plusieurs fois ah ben non je
vais parler avec un débit normal je vais
te le donner une seule fois et après on
va même parler de choses et d'autres
comme dans la vraie vie ok alors je dis
pas que je vais le retenir je vais
essayer de le retenir c'est une bonne
première marge je trouve tu es prêt je
suis prêt alors sois concentré le numéro
de téléphone c'est le 09 72 39 40 50
voilà je l'ai donné qu'une seule fois
donc maintenant on va pouvoir un peu
discuter d'autre chose il est très joli
atelier tu la construit il y a longtemps
alors c'est terrible là parce que
j'étais en train d'essayer de me répéter
le numéro de téléphone mais tu me poses
une question sur mon atelier j'ai aussi
envie de répondre à cette question c'est
un très vieil atelier parce qu'à
l'origine c'était une forge voilà c'est
un atelier qui a plus de 100 ans je
crois qu'il a été bâti en 1896 donc
c'est pas toi qui l'a
construits quand je suis arrivé
aujourd'hui on m'a raconté quelque chose
sur l'acier qui est ici oui l'acier qui
a servi à construire cet atelier
provient des ateliers Eiffel c'est
génial ça aurait pu être des bouts de
Tour Eiffel s'ils avaient été orienté
ailleurs pas sûr parce que Eiffel avait
bien calculé son truc c'était un
ingénieur donc il avait fait en sorte
qu'il y ait pas trop trop de pertes
voilà pour rentabiliser l'affaire les
ingénieurs calcule bien également au
niveau des finances moi j'aime bien
parce que là on a une vraie conversation
comme dans la vraie vie ce qui me permet
de te demander maintenant c'était quoi
mon numéro de téléphone et là ça va être
beaucoup beaucoup plus difficile de te
répondre alors je sais que ça commence
par
09 72 et après j'avais fixé un
département 39 le Jura pas si mal
j'étais parti en fait sur Ariège Sarthe
et Jura c'est passionnant ce que tu dis
d'instin tu as compris que les nombres
les chiffres les quantités ça ne
correspond à rien dans notre cerveau ça
a pas de sens un chiffre ou une quantité
donc essayez de le ramener à quelque
chose de logique et bien moi j'ai
justement une méthode qui permet de
rendre ça très logique et de donner
beaucoup de sens pour le cerveau une
méthode infaillible qui va me permettre
de te faire retenir n'importe quel
numéro de téléphone mais pas quelques
secondes quelques heures ou quelques
jours ah ça c'est super parce que pour
le moment si je compose 09 72 39 je ne
vais pas tomber sur Fabien olicard non
je pense tu tomberas d'ailleurs sur ce
tuto au final parce que en plus de ça tu
les as même pas associés entre eux donc
tu les as mis dans une mémoire
temporaire qu'on appelle la mémoire de
travail c'est une mémoire qui est très
quotidienne la mémoire de travail on
l'utilise beaucoup mais ça permet de
retenir cette information
différents au maximum pour une durée de
5 à 6 secondes j'avais gardé en mémoire
ce chiffre 7 pas plus de cette
information c'est c'est très très peu au
bout du compte c'est très très peu moi
je suis d'accord avec toi d'ailleurs de
manière générale dans la vie on va
revenir à notre numéro de téléphone tu
me le rappelles déjà j'ai mes
départements qui m'aident 09 72 39 et
après oh mon Dieu où suis-je et tu sais
que plus le temps va passer moins tu
seras sûr de ce que tu vas me dire tu te
souvenais encore des départements mais
c'est ça au fur et à mesure c'est lequel
en premier lequel en deuxième c'est
compliqué alors que avec la méthode que
je vais te donner ça va être infaillible
tu seras avec assurance en plus sans
aucun doute c'est très agréable de
ressentir aussi qu'on sait vraiment
quelque chose cette méthode elle
s'appelle la table de rappel la table de
rappel elle consiste à faire en sorte
que chaque nombre et chaque chiffre soit
associé à une image parce que l'image ça
donne du sens au cerveau les nombres les
quantités ça n'a aucun sens pour le
cerveau une image ça en a un donc on va
composer une sorte de correspondance un
chiffre égale une image ça c'est le
fonctionnement de base de la table de
rappel qui a inventé ça qui l'a inventé
c'est pas très clair mais on est sûr
d'une chose c'est que le mathématicien
pierre et rigole en 1634 utilisait déjà
une méthode très similaire il appelait
ça lui la méthode chiffre lait donc il
avait associé chaque chiffre à une
lettre une consonne en l'occurrence pour
lui le 4 c'était un r le 3 c'était un M
alors il avait pas fait au hasard le 4
quand on le dessine comme ça ça lui
rappelle un peu un r c'est vrai tout à
fait la lettre M majuscule je la dessine
dans le vide si on la retourne un petit
peu ça fait un 3 ça ressemble à un 3
exactement il y avait une logique donc
c'est comme ça qui composait un petit
peu son image mais c'est des images qui
représentent des chiffres comment il
faisait si il voulait retenir je sais
pas moi 43 par exemple alors là c'est
pas compliqué on garde les consonnes
qu'il a créé et on va rajouter des
voyelles entre ces consonnes pour créer
un mot calissante donc on va mettre par
exemple une voyelle entre le R et le m
et une voyelle après 43 c'est donc RM et
bien ajoutant des voyelles ça fait rame
on rajoute un a au milieu et un e à la
fin et donc on sait que l'image pour 43
c'est une rame et lui avait fait ça
pourtant les nombres chiffres de 1 à 100
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on ce qu'on fait
quand on pratique la table de rappel on
crée ses propres images c'est la méthode
que tu utilises toi alors moi j'utilise
pas la table de rappel de pierre et
rigone la mienne allait encore plus
simple que la sienne c'est une rime
numérique avec constante une rime
numérique avec constante on va où là
c'est peut-être pas plus simple à dire
mais c'est plus simple à faire en
réalité je convertis tous mes nombres
chiffres un peu comme un code secret en
faisant en sorte que mes images riment
avec le nombre ou avec le chiffre un
exemple concret en 1 c'est un sapin en
deux j'ai du feu en trois j'ai une croix
en quatre un plâtre donc il y a une
vraie correspondance on l'entend et
c'est toi qui a choisi ces
correspondances c'est absolument moi qui
ai choisi ces correspondances et c'est
même encore plus efficace quand les
choisit soi-même quand ça vient de soi
parce qu'on n'a pas à s'entraîner à le
retenir ça vient de nous spontanément et
après pour les là où il y a une dizaine
j'utilise le principe de la constante
par exemple j'ai déterminé que pour
toute la trentaine tout ce qui allait
commencer par 30 commenceraient par la
lettre P ça c'est arbitraire je l'ai
décidé comme ça et après je garde mon
idée de rime 31 c'est un port saints un
pneu etc etc donc on reprend pour toi 0
c'est de l'eau en 1 j'ai un sapin en
deux c'est du feu en 3 c'est une croix 4
un plâtre 5 à 5 6 une 6 7 une tête 8 ml
9 tu vas le trouver tout seul un œuf
absolument et en 10 la police et
maintenant que tu connais bien la
théorie on va faire la mise en pratique
tu vas convertir ce numéro de téléphone
en une série d'image dans ta tête il y a
des images que tu as déjà il y en a
d'autres que tu vas devoir créer tout
l'intérêt de la méthode donc mon numéro
de téléphone commencer par 09 09 donc on
a dit que zéro c'était l'eau oui et neuf
c'est l'oeuf ça c'est parfait très bien
après tu vas m'oublier ton système
départemental en garde mes images je
veux une image pour le 72 alors déjà
faut lui trouver une lettre constante
qui va marcher pour tout de 70 à 79 ce
serait quelle lettre je peux y aller au
hasard oui un thé un thé mais moi je
trouve pas ça hasardeux parce que le 7
me fait penser un peu un thé très bien
ça c'est pas mal
le 72 bah faut que ça commence par t il
faut que ça finisse par 72 12
c'est formidable voilà et bien on sait
que 72 c'est Toulouse ensuite 39 avec la
même méthode pour tous les nombres de 30
à 39 je sais pas moi qu'est-ce que tu
dises quoi toi le P mais le B c'est pas
mal aussi le B je pense que le 3 ça fait
un peu un B ok mais il faut que ça
finisse comme 39 facile si ça commence
par un B et ça finit par œuf
39 boeuf c'est déjà presque associé 39
boeufs très bien 40 qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait celui-ci alors tu vois 40 je
l'avais oublié oui c'est vrai il faut
une cette dizaine la quarantaine et puis
ça finissent par ante ainsi très bien
donc un mot qui commence donc par C qui
finissent par ante il y en a plein là il
y a chantent charpente charmant voilà
charmante charmante c'est sympa c'est
pas le plus facile parce que on a pas
forcément d'image spontanément mais on
pourra le travailler quand même moi par
exemple pour 40 j'ai une autre
alternative moi c'est une planche à
voile pourquoi parce que je trouve que
le chiffre 4 me rappelle une planche à
voile et 0 c'est de l'eau les planches à
voile ça va dans l'eau donc j'y trouve
ma propre logique donc là tu as
carrément associé une image seule qui
est déconnectée du reste des chiffres
entre 40 et 49 pour le nombre 40 pour le
nombre 40 on a le droit de le faire tous
les coups sont permis d'accord et le
dernier et le dernier le 55
c'est pareil il faut que ça finisse par
pente oui il faut une autre lettre que
tu peux déterminer je pense à un mot là
tout de suite c'est en regardant mon
décor tu vois donc je veux dire un P
pour la cinquantaine qui finit par an
voilà c'est un mot que j'aime bien c'est
le mot plante et là c'est rigolo tu l'as
fait en inversé tu as pensé à plante tu
t'es dit ben je garderai le P ça marche
très bien aussi donc là c'est pas mal
parce que tu nous as donné des images
pour tout et bien maintenant il va
falloir que tu me crées une histoire qui
intègre tous ces mots une histoire
courte mais une histoire linéaire faut
que les mots arrivent dans l'ordre sinon
tu vas appeler n'importe qui ah oui donc
ça peut être au bord de l'eau j'ai
trouvé un oeuf juste à côté de la ville
de Toulouse où il y avait un boeuf et de
charmante plante ça c'est la version
débutant oui c'est-à-dire tu as
aggloméré les mots au plus simple mais
c'est pas très joyeux il y a plein
beaucoup d'émotions il y a pas beaucoup
de choc alors on pourrait garder ton
histoire et se dire au bord de l'eau tu
cuisinais un œuf pour tes amis de
Toulouse oui bah tu crois qu'ils
arrivent pas du tout c'est un bœuf qui
arrive à la place
il est marrant ce bœuf mettrais un grand
sourire il est marrant mais il est
charmant quand même ce bœuf et en plus
il t'a amené un cadeau il a sous le bras
une petite plante et là tu es en train
de créer des images un peu rigolote et
ça va encore plus te marquer absolument
mais pour ça il faut prendre un peu de
temps oui absolument il faut prendre ce
temps on a pu l'habitude de faire ce
qu'on appelle l'encodage pour la mémoire
prendre le temps d'apprendre à le faire
mais en plus la table de rappel on
l'apprend au bénéfice d'une vie entière
on prend un peu de temps aujourd'hui toi
et moi mais ce temps-là tu ne le
reprendras plus tard mais c'est un peu
compliqué quand même parce que au moment
où tu m'as annoncé ton numéro de
téléphone et bien il faut que je
construis cette histoire quasiment
instantanément oui il y a deux
difficultés la première c'est que il va
falloir commencer par prendre un temps
dans sa vie pour faire les
correspondances d'image de 1 à 100 ça
c'est la première étape et ça on le sait
pour toute sa vie mieux que l'alphabet
puisque de toute manière on a construit
les images nous-mêmes et ensuite il
faudra s'entraîner à le faire un petit
peu de temps en temps et ça devient une
automatisme comme le reste mais il faut
prendre ce temps là absolument ça c'est
nécessaire l'Allier de la mémoire c'est
le temps et la tension mais donc
maintenant j'ai bien retenu quand même
sans avoir construit l'histoire que le
numéro de téléphone qui n'est pas solide
Fabien je suis sûr qu'il l'a inventé
j'ai bien retenu que c'était l'eau l'œuf
que derrière il y avait Toulouse qu'il y
avait un bœuf un bœuf charmant et que la
dernière chose qui qui l'adorait les
plantes ben oui voilà c'est sympa donc
voilà c'est rentré mais c'est là où
c'est très ingénieux finalement parce
que toutes ces images et bien elles vont
être stockées non pas dans la mémoire de
travail on l'a dit dans une mémoire à
long terme ce qu'on appelle la mémoire
épisodique exactement qui est une
mémoire qui absorbe nos souvenirs de vie
on n'a pas besoin de réviser pour savoir
les vacances qu'on a passé le mois
dernier on s'en souvient c'est rangé
dans cette mémoire bon alors je suis
très très content j'ai pu mémoriser un
numéro de téléphone seulement mon cher
Fabien aujourd'hui les numéros de
téléphone on ne les mémorise plus dans
notre mémoire on a des smartphones pour
faire tout ça donc finalement est-ce que
c'est bien
utile de se construire une table de
rappel comme ceci est-ce que tu
sous-entends tes méthodes ne servent
plus non elles servent encore et pour
plein de choses là c'était un bon
exemple de travail mais dans le
quotidien par exemple la table de rappel
elle peut nous servir à retenir notre
liste de courses ah alors ça ça
m'intéresse parce que je fais souvent
les cours alors moi je vais te faire
économiser une feuille de papier et vous
aussi en même temps puisque cette liste
de courses elle va exister dans votre
tête c'est la même méthode mais en plus
simple en plus alors je te donne une
liste de courses comme ça spontanément
de l'eau de la farine du pain une
saucisse du saumon des bananes et de la
confiture de fraise ça va cette chose à
acheter c'est pas énorme j'ai dit quoi
comme liste de courses déjà
c'est aller encore plus vite que le
numéro c'était le plus vite et je ne m'y
attendais pas absolument et c'était un
petit peu le but et bien ce soir nous
boirons de l'eau et nous mangeons de la
farine c'est pas mal les deux premiers
déjà là ça fait pas un gros repas je
sais pas si je viendrai manger des
bananes
ça c'est pas mal alors je vais te donner
la méthode pour retenir ça pas assez de
vitesse mais quasiment à cette vitesse
une fois qu'on est habitué on va non pas
reconstruire des images en entier on va
repartir sur les images que je t'ai
données tout à l'heure de 1 à 10 tu vas
associer à chaque image de chaque
chiffre l'ingrédient tu dois acheter en
1 j'ai un sapin il va falloir l'associer
à l'image du lait alors qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire tout de suite j'imagine un
sapin de Noël avec des bouteilles de
lait suspendu à mon sapin à la place des
petites boules décoratives tout à fait
en deux moi je veux acheter de la farine
de la farine et donc le 2 c'était le feu
donc je vais partir du feu le feu a pris
dans un paquet de farine et je vois un
paquet de farine en feu ok parfait une
belle flamme sur mon paquet de farine
j'aime bien parce que je te vois
décrocher le regard pour rentrer dans
ton imaginaire ça veut dire que ça
marche bien en trois j'achète une
saucisse alors on a dit que trois
c'était associé à une croix donc on imag
une croix faite avec des saucisses des
saucisses de Toulouse là qu'il faut une
croix très bien on en revient à Toulouse
voilà en 4 du pain parce que quand même
pour manger j'aime bien avoir du pain
donc 4 c'est plâtre donc bah moi
j'imagine
du pain très dur fait non pas de la
farine mais avec du plâtre j'ai déjà un
peu mal aux dents
en 5 j'ai dit qu'on allait acheter du
saumon le saumon le 5 c'est le zinc oui
comme j'ai un zinc juste à côté de moi
et bien j'imagine un beau saumon là posé
sur le zinc parfait en plus tu utilises
du décor que tu connais j'ai l'image en
tête ensuite une banane donc là c'est le
le sixième aliment que je dois acheter
au marché en 6 c'est la scie
[Musique]
je suis une banane classique et enfin
dernier de la confiture de fraises alors
la confiture de fraises 7 c'est la tête
oui désolé Fabien mais j'imagine
esquiver mais confiture sur la tête mais
ça me dérange pas j'adore la fraise
alors ça va très très bien là tu as fait
100% du travail c'est-à-dire que là il y
a pas besoin de composer une histoire ou
quoi que ce soit le fait d'avoir pensé à
ces images fait que ça va rester vif
dans ta mémoire épisodique et là
maintenant tu es capable de me restituer
pas forcément dans l'ordre la liste de
courses alors je te rappelle juste qu'on
avait cette chose à acheter ok tu vas
essayer de me les redonner la première
image qui me vient en tête c'est le
sapin avec les bouteilles de lait
suspendus normal je dois rapporter du
lait la deuxième image qui me vient en
mémoire
c'est mon paquet de farine en feu il
faut que je rapporte de la farine en 3
les saucisses qui forment une croix et
là c'est génial parce que je vois dans
tes yeux qu'à chaque fois tu repars de
l'image donc la croix le feu le sapin et
c'est ça qui rappelle l'ingrédient
ensuite formidable en 4 en 4 ça rime
avec plâtre c'est du pain je vois mon
pain comme je te l'ai écrit tout à
l'heure à côté de mon sac de plâtre 5
c'est le zinc et là je visualise le
saumon sur le sein le zinc 6 c'est la
scie qui si la banane que je dois
rapporter également et enfin en 7 mon
cher Fabien c'est la confiture de
fraises que tu as sur la tête alors
c'est parfait ce qui est très rigolo
c'est que d'une
100% sans faute je te mets la note
maximale ce qui me fait beaucoup rire
c'est que tu as osé utiliser un élément
de chez toi dis-toi que pendant des
semaines quand tu arriveras devant les
Indes tu penseras du saumon ça va
marcher aussi dans l'autre sens et ce
qui est très bluffant c'est que la site
demain on te demande non plus la liste
de courses mais c'était quoi le sixième
ingrédient tu seras capable de le donner
donc ça montre aussi le côté très
malléable et puissant de cette mémoire
alors c'est très bien pour faire les
courses mais c'est aussi très bien pour
mémoriser une recette du coup pour
mémoriser une recette pour mémoriser une
liste de courses mais même les étapes
d'un discours le plan d'un cours que
j'ai à donner par exemple si je dois
faire un grand oral pour présenter un
sujet à l'école si je dois pour mon
travail me rappeler de plusieurs étapes
à suivre on peut le décliner à l'infini
il faut juste prendre le temps on l'a
dit d'établir cette table de rappel et
les constantes exactement de 1 à 100 on
se rajoute le 0 mais par convention on
garde en général l'eau on prend ce temps
là on pas obligé de tout faire la même
journée on peut faire de 1 à 10 le
premier jour de 11 à 20 le deuxième jour
etc etc comme les images elles viendront
de vous elle s'est rendu logique
implacable et très ancré pour vous et ce
qui est génial dans cette méthode je le
répète un petit peu c'est que on ne
stoppe plus les informations dans notre
mémoire de travail notre mémoire à court
terme mais dans une mémoire a beaucoup
plus long terme la mémoire épisodique
c'est une mémoire qui fonctionne comme
un album de photos finalement absolument
c'est celle qui fait que demain je vais
raconter ce bon moment qu'on a passé
ensemble parce qu'il sera dans ma
mémoire épisodique encore très vif voilà
mais qui a le mérite cette mémoire de
mémoriser à la fois des choses que l'on
a vécues ou des choses que l'on a
imaginé et c'est ce qu'avait compris
pierre et rigonne c'est ce qui avait
compris les Grecs etc c'est que cette
mémoire ne fait pas la différence entre
l'expérience et l'imaginaire donc autant
en profiter ben écoute je te remercie
beaucoup Fabien c'était très clair je
suis ravi parce que j'ai appris une
méthode de mémorisation vous aussi
j'espère je suis désolé je regarde ma
montre parce que je dois aller au marché
faire les courses tu viens avec moi la
liste est longue c'est pas pour m'en
souvenir c'est pour rapporter les
courses
voilà j'espère que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo vous savez maintenant ce qu'il
vous reste à faire pour booster votre
mémoire table de rappel plus constante
si vous avez aimé cet épisode n'hésitez
pas à liker excellente fin de semaine à
toutes et à tous et n'oubliez pas à
dimanche prochain
[Applaudissements]